[Musik]
moin von der cebit in hannover jonas
jansen und carsten knop teil des cbt im
stil von der faz net liebe jonas zwei
tage cebit liegen jetzt schon hinter uns
was ist dein erster eindruck
ja es voller als ich erwartet hatte nach
der umstellung des konzeptes also ich
glaub auch die macher hat ein bisschen
sorge dass die hier weniger leute nach
hannover bekommen und vor allem weil
vorher ja der abgesang irgendwie immer
wieder von hinter vorgehaltener hand zu
hören war von verschiedenen leuten bin
ich schon erstaunt wie viele leute ihren
laufen ja die hatten angst dass nämlich
gar keiner kommt und dann waren gestern
beim konzert 10.000 leute da und die
vortragsveranstaltung laufen ziemlich
gut nach meinem ersten eindruck geht er
auch so ne also dafür dass dann quasi am
ersten tag ja hier noch ganz viel
aufgebaut wurde das preise so ein
messetag er war mit ein bisschen
konferenz noch drumherum war selbst da
schon einiges los jetzt könnte das
wetter noch ein bisschen besser werden
verglichen im rest von deutschland hier
glaube ich arschkalt tschuldigung ja das
wird morgen und also donnerstag und
freitag ist besser ja und dann könnte
nämlich auch intel endlich mit seiner
welle x erfolg haben die haben draußen
nämlich so eine welle aufgebaut auf dem
man surfen kann
draußen auf einer welle surfen drohnen
fliegen ja auch eine ganze menge um
abends gibt es immer zum abschluss noch
eine drohnen show aber dir geht auch
eine sache tierisch auf die nerven hast
du gesagt welche ist das denn er weiß es
wirklich nicht mehr sehen kann liebe
unternehmen
bitte hört auf pepper zu kaufen also
dass dieser roboter von softbank der
wirklich süß aussieht und toll ist und
so aber das hat jetzt wirklich seit
jahren
ich weiß nicht ich glaube vor zwei
jahren auf der cebit haben wir das erste
video über pepper gemacht da war das
noch relativ neu und jetzt hat das
wirklich jeder bayer hat glaube ich zwei
dabei allein ein bisschen das gegenteil
von modernen zwischen wenn man wirklich
cool sein will er ist mein papa zu hause
gibt es andere sache ja man hat zum
beispiel die faz digitec wenn man cool
sein
ja das stimmt
übrigens faz digitec ist tatsächlich auf
der cebit neue app die alle unsere
digitale themen und technikthemen aus
fasnet und der zeitung bündelt kompakt
in einer handy app gibt es jetzt
kostenlos zum download und während der
cebit auch vollkommen kostenfrei wer mag
guckt er doch gerne mal rein und die
zugriffszahlen sind auch ziemlich gut
die leute interessiert die verbindung
von technischen wandel und
gesellschaftlichen auswirkungen wirklich
sehr und sie machen sich sorgen um ihren
arbeitsplatz sie wissen nicht genau was
mit künstlicher intelligenz anzufangen
ist dazu erfährt man hier eine ganze
menge stimmt ja schon also das ist war
am ersten tag auf den auf den stage ist
schon ziemliches thema unter den ganzen
industrie vertretern von apatech über
bdi bis zum accenture deutschland chef
der hier ziemlich den unternehmen die
leviten gelesen hat dass sie zu
zögerlich sind und gleichzeitig sind
aber irgendwie viele also wenn ihr
darüber geredet wird dass vor allem die
daten gesammelt werden müssen damit
alles schlauer wird muss man natürlich
auch darüber reden was damit passiert
und wie das irgendwie die leute betrifft
ich meine dann irgendwie zu sagen die
deutschen sind besonders zögerlich hilft
ja auch nicht weiter also das ist ja hat
ja oft ein grund warum man irgendwie
unternehmen misstraut wie sie mit den
daten umgehen weil es ist halt viel zu
oft wenn wir nicht so richtig gut machen
aufbruch übrigens es hier auf der cebit
eine ganze menge wir melden uns sehr
hier aus halle 27 wo auch die faz ihren
stand hat aber auch dutzende start ups
die wirklich pfiffige ideen präsentieren
wer also noch es schafft war den tagen
die mit gutem wetter auf jeden fall
kombiniert sein werden also donnerstag
und freitag nach hannover zu kommen
sollte in der halle 27
mit einem frischen blick auf eine
jugendliche deutscher it szene schauen
und hier in der halle 27 kann ich nur
empfehlen den stand vom karlsruher
institut für technologie die haben so
einen humanoiden roboter da sieht man
auch mal wie viel technik noch braucht
also der kann schon einiges aber wenn er
dann den menschen helfen soll bei
bestimmten tätigkeiten da merkt man
schon dass es noch ein bisschen lang
so misst und trotzdem sind die ja nicht
blöd die leute beim k et also das sind
ja pfiffige ingenieure und trotzdem also
ganz in der zukunft immer noch nicht
darüber kann man schon sehen wir uns auf
der cebit vielleicht morgen oder
jederzeit auf fasnet / cebit danke fürs
zuhören
bis dann
[Musik]